you know you mentioned uh link later and
then uh robert rodriguez
also the the duploss brothers where was
the chair yeah
film was it louisiana yeah the uh the
duploss brothers
uh definitely come from louisiana i also
lived there for a couple years and
uh recently i did a season of a tv show
down there that we wrote
um and and it was the duploss brothers
kind of
way of doing things uh that we made it
it was called home remedy
and we made it for a couple hundred
dollars and it was five 20-minute
episodes
um and it was it was truly a labor of
love it was it was a very
tricky project to pull off but you know
it like you mentioned the duploss
brothers they are truly
um the model i think for the way that i
try to approach filmmaking a lot of
times um
i've got their book on my shelf i really
enjoy you know their work and
i enjoy their attitude because they know
that you know
you can make a hundred dollar movie it's
probably not going to be the best movie
but
it can at least get the the ball rolling
and i think a lot of times
as filmmakers that's what we struggle
with right it's
how do we get the ball rolling you know
how do we take that first step get the
script out of our head
um and a lot of times i think it's just
not it's it's not overthinking it you
know because i think
the process is so in-depth that a lot of
times
um you know we can get lost in the sauce
so to speak so
you know it's kind of like before you
jump into all of these different steps
of you know cinematography and casting
and lighting
you know if you just have a little film
you need to make to get it out of your
system to even know if you like
filmmaking
um just do it get some friends make it
happen and and i think it's that um
attitude i've tried to take and a lot of
times you know even now
i i just made a feature film last year
and i was the cinematographer and that
scared
the crap out of me at the time you know
i enjoy
shooting but i always you know before
that i always made sure i had a
dedicated cinematographer
and it just so happened the time we
wanted to film uh the folks i was
interested in we couldn't we couldn't
get a hold of so it was either
make it then or wait months and months
and so obviously
with the state of the world right now i
don't think we could have made it happen
if we waited months and months so
i'm quite happy that you know i did kind
of just jump in and do it and it was the
duploss brothers way of just saying well
hey don't overthink it you know how to
shoot
you're not you're not going to try to
win an oscar with your cinematography
here
um you have the steps you need you know
how to operate a camera
just catch the story and let the rest
take care of itself and so
i try to approach it um in that kind of
a naturalistic way a lot of times
and what were one or two things that you
learned how to course correct
from being your own dp that maybe if you
hadn't have
sort of been you know had to land on
your feet so to speak and do it you
wouldn't have known
well i think i think the good thing with
being my own dp
is i had the the privilege of you know
working with some awesome dps in the
past for other projects i've done
um my sonic my cinematographer for son
of clowns my first feature
uh he was super amazing and i got to
learn a lot from him in addition to
everyone else i've worked with and i
also come from the
corporate world of making video projects
in the music video world where a lot of
times the the crews and budgets are a
lot smaller
so you get used to being your own
cinematographer in a pinch and that's
happened to me a couple times
so i think that definitely helped as
well um
and again i do think it was kind of the
thing where i had to
um really kind of learn to walk and chew
gum at the same time if you will it was
figuring out you know hey how much time
do i need to spend
you know pushing buttons and getting
that iso just right and getting the
lighting just right
because you know the director side of me
is thinking well we've got
you know an hour before the sun sets and
i really need to sit down with this
actor
and give him 10 minutes of time to
really run through this rehearsal and at
a certain point you kind of have to do
the math in your head and say okay well
you know
do i push those buttons or do i do that
with him and so
you know i think i'd like to think that
i found a way to sort of balance
everything around where i kept the
setups pretty lean and pretty simple
so i didn't have to stress a lot of
times about that
where you know i think if i was trying
to make you know some big action
chase movie where there was a lot of
moving parts i don't think i could have
done it that way
um but you know a guy talking to another
guy in a field
while he's walking away that seemed a
little more doable in that situation so
i think when you do stuff uh you know
like shoot your own film
it's kind of designing it from the
get-go to say okay i'm not going to put
myself
into a crazy you know film scenario like
a car chase scene that i know i can't
really pull off as a one-man band
so it's kind of you know crafting it to
what you know could work in that
situation
and and even then it doesn't make it
easy but it just sort of you know
takes a little pre-production to kind of
figure out you know if it's even
feasible
so so you had almost two parts of your
brain
yeah for lack of a better word arguing
like what one is saying well we this
this footage is too grainy i need more
light and the other one's saying but
we've got to hurry up and
feed the crew kind of thing yeah it got
kind of tug of war
yeah definitely and it was funny too
because
a lot of times uh you know i would tell
the actors i'd say
hey you know i'm i'm sorry i didn't give
you enough time for that scene i felt
like we were rushing and they were like
no no you're good you're doing all these
things it's great
and and so i think a lot of times as
filmmakers a lot of that's in our own
head
and a lot of it's self-imposed and i
think it's good because it shows that we
care
and it shows that you know we don't want
to just rush through something we want
to take the time we can
um but i think a lot of times we're very
tough on ourselves mentally
if we're doing filmmaking um especially
indie filmmaking
where the crews are small and you're
spending a lot of time you know with
your own script and your own
cinematography and you know you know
you're going to edit it later and just
kind of all these little things like
that
and i think it's interesting just
because it reminds you to
to be a little kinder to yourself
sometimes and i think your crews can
can see if you mean well a lot of times
so
do you think there's a different
protocol on a set in the south
maybe more you know yes please thank you
whereas maybe other parts and nothing
no no slight to them but just things are
done differently
that if a filmmaker goes from a
different region
that they have to kind of know oh hey
i'm here
where maybe they're not going to say yes
please and thank you and it might just
seem a little more abrupt but it doesn't
mean they're mad at me
kind of thing oh yeah definitely um i
think where you make films
and how you make films is going to
dictate
the kind of you know quote unquote
unspoken vernacular of your film set
i've worked on you know bigger crews
when i was living in louisiana you know
new orleans is a big production hub
so i'd go crew on a lot of things there
just to freelance and make some money
and a lot of the crews there were you
know coming from la and we were you know
doing the shorthand and like you said
there was not a lot of the the please
and thank you it was a lot of times like
grab that do this
go go and and that's appropriate because
you know that is a
large television show that we were
working on
and there are deadlines and there are
people staying in hotels and people that
need to get picked up and leave by a
certain time
and certainly those things happen in
indie film too
but i think a lot of times when you're
making an indie film it kind of
comes from a place of of love a lot of
times rather than profit
a lot of times it comes from a place of
hey we just want to tell a story
um maybe we'll make money maybe we won't
but i think that unspoken vernacular
kind of separates things a little bit
and i don't think one is better
or worse than the other um because i
know a lot of people who work outside of
the
you know the studio system or outside of
you know new york or la
they kind of think oh well that's the
way they do it this is the way i do it
um i think it's just different strokes
for different folks and i think that
when you're making
your project you have to just be honest
with yourself and say okay
do i know what i'm making because if i'm
making something with like five people
and i know them really well and that's
the whole crew we're probably going to
have a very different
um onset kind of shorthand than when i
was working in new orleans and i was
working on the big cruise with like
50 60 70 people and you know that you're
working with people who are in unions
and this and that and it's just it's a
different experience and
again it's not to say one is better than
the other it's just that
you know on one particular week you're
here and next you're there and i think
you can go back and forth so yeah
you